c'est non car ous les marrons 8 sur
trois premières les fêtes c'est aussi
bien sûr l'époque des trucs tout le
monde aime les truffes mais il ya truffé
truffe comment reconnaître un chien
comestibles d'infirmer niveau là le
problème
la truffe de ce chien n'est pas
comestible c'est un chien qui a une vol
si vous rencontrez un chien avec une
wolf comme ça projeté le c'est un fear
vénéneux chats domestiques ne présente
pas de vol chaque massif soliste pas un
mouvement comment le chat comestibles
c'est qu'ils s'arrangent pour les chiens
mangent pas plus qu'on ne sait pas bien
on peut pas parler de mon travail est un
sujet dont vous me dire ça mais c'était
pour parler des truffes tu vois moi je
voulais faire un sujet sur les primes en
voici cartouches c'est un espagnol
berrichon l'epagnol le berrichon est un
animal charmant malheureusement il est
très peureux voyez vous comme il frémit
l'animal qui a tendance à frémir il et
frémissant et bien dès qu'il commence à
frémir
vous prenez un petit peu vous couvrez
d'abord mais vous prenez un peu de
farine blueant la farine plus longue
avec la farine plus rampante de cuisine
de luxe
bah c'est un peu nous faire rire
pas faire ça on peut pas faire d'autres
choses c'est pas c'est pas vraiment déçu
parce que je vais pas glisser
adroitement salles permanentes chalon ne
pas le faire partout 30 millions d'amis
tout auteur ou s'écrit 8 sur 2 3e voici
cartouches
c'est un boxeur à poil mou comme vous le
voyez c'est un boxeur le boxeur poids
lourds ressemble à tous les autres
boxeurs sauf qu'il a les poils durs la
grande qualité du boxeur à poil mou
c'est que c'est un animal très attachant
pour éviter qu'il n'attache utiliser la
toile france plonge dans la poêle dans
tous les bons coups de bras ça c'est pas
possible
tout quoi c'est gênant que fait trois
fois qu'on recommence sur commence avec
la quetsche est toujours celle que pas
moi qui fabrique les sympas de 38 ans
nelly docteur house les noirs vie sur
quatre premières et bien voici
cartouches cartouche est un bassin géant
le bassin géant comme vous le savez
c'est un bassin qui a toutes les
caractéristiques du passé ordinaire sauf
qui est un peu plus court sur pattes
c'est un animal charmant malheureusement
il a un grand défaut c'est que c'est un
animal qui est assez fuyant c'est à dire
qu'il est il a tendance à ceux à se
sauver alors s'il se sauver s'il se
sauve
faites le revenir dans quoi dans l'huile
vidange lui il vit dans john cette
demoiselle but de mes lacets
mais envoyait même pas l'étiquette rien
faire c'est non non
[Musique]